Oh
[Music]
I'll tell you what this next audience
Wi-Fi out straddle your dad here and sir
you cake little lady you're a lucky girl
and I'm a lucky octopus apparently
excuse me I'll just I'll lead the way
okey-dokey then
I'm normal this is the seductive
pre-dinner dance okay don't mind me I'm
gonna okay like the rhythmic undulation
of my arm I'm a married squid octopus
whatever but I am straddling your bed
ever so seductive
okay I'm done fluffing your pillows
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
here comes plain here comes the frickin
airplane oh this is a familiar feeling
do it here what chances do I sit hail
the sweet moon air of Venus this room
counterclockwise to the rings Oh
although two times look at me from the
greatest suck it very hard so I went in
knowing that the only way I survive is
to infiltrate the Vietcong via their
dicks so I went into their tunnel no
you're not oh my god did I lose that
okay got it
oh don't got it no stop yelling
thanks for watching all of the videos in
this compilation are available in the
description so check them out and if
you'd like to see more in the future
please leave a like to let me know if
you enjoyed this video and you'd like to
see more on a daily basis please
subscribe today or if you're already
subscribed share this video with a
thread thanks again for watching and
I'll see you in the next video bye bye